[Music]
thank you
well hello everyone welcome to the
program I'd like to know
this is one of our favorite programs
here at Secrets unsealed in some TV
we get a chance to do a lot of research
into the questions that are asked and
it's edification for us as well as for
those who watch the program
uh this is a question and answer program
where you send us your questions and we
do the research and provide the answers
if there are answers to the questions uh
if you want to send us your questions
you'll see on the screen the address the
electronic address where you can send
them it's TV at some tv.org once again
TV at some
tv.org I have with me my good friend uh
CA Murray who is associate speaker among
many other things here also a media
consultant here at Secrets unsealed and
he's been a real blessing to our
ministry we're so proud and happy to
have him thank you for being here CA and
God bless always good to study the word
of God with you Pastor something that I
personally enjoy and am edified by amen
amen well we don't want to be without
prayer we need the help of the Holy
Spirit even though we've done the
research and we've prayed for the Holy
Spirit we still need the Holy Spirit to
answer the questions so if you would
pray for us that would be great be glad
to do so father God again we we come to
you with a request for the presence and
power of your Holy Spirit we know that
spiritual things are spiritually
discerned so we ask for the discernment
of Christ
we asked for a discernment to understand
the questions and to find the answers we
ask for the power of your spirit so that
our words
are your words and that they are made
clear to those who need to hear a word
from the Lord so we thank you Father for
your presence and your promise to answer
the prayer of faith in Jesus name amen
amen amen
okay what do we have
all right um this is a question uh that
has come in from Wendy Burgos and thank
you Wendy for your question why did God
not kill the devil that's the question
actually that comes up kind of a lot uh
you know just do it end it just we we've
gone through six thousand years of
turmoil why not just end it up front
um and there are two and we'll just put
them all and then we'll take them one by
one do we know the background of sports
and should we as Christians get involved
in sports should Christian kids play
video games all right so three different
sort of Slants on things let's deal with
the devil one first I would like to say
I I think one of the reasons that God
could not kill him right away of course
God could had he chose to but in his
wisdom chose not to was and we see this
in the spirit of Prophecy because of the
way the devil profit his argument you
know he's saying God is unfair God is
unjust and then for God to just blot him
out would would almost give strength to
the argument plus the fact that sin was
a new entity in the universe and the
angels in fact even Satan at its very
outset didn't know what he was dealing
with so when you've got something brand
new
um that nobody really knows the sum and
substance of sometimes you have to let
it play out so they can see and of
course all of the questions were
answered at the cross but until that
time there was some sympathy for Satan
because the way structured his argument
uh in the minds of some angels well that
sympathy was erased and dealt with at
the cross yeah you know the Apostle Paul
wrote In First Corinthians chapter 13
some very very important words in verse
9 he says for we know in part yes and we
prophesy in part
and then he continues saying but when
that which is perfect has come then that
which is in part will be done away and
then in verse 12 he says for now we see
in a mirror dimly
but then face to face now I know in part
but then I shall know just as I also am
known so you know my attitude
is that we cannot explain everything in
this life true why does God allow sin to
exist for six thousand years well we
know it's because God wanted to show
what kind of universe we would have if
he had allowed Lucifer to occupy the
throne
but you know why didn't he end it sooner
why did he allow what he allowed during
the course of history
we'll finally have the answers when we
get to heaven because now we know in
part we see through a glass dimly or
Darkly as the King James version says
but my attitude has been
I can trust God yes and someday what I
can't understand now I will understand
God doesn't say explain everything God
says trust me that my way is the best
way and someday you will understand yes
so it's just a matter of having faith
that what God does and what God allows
all has an ultimate purpose that we
don't really understand right now yes
but what you say is absolutely right if
God had destroyed Lucifer right after he
sinned uh the the Heavenly beings would
have said well Lucifer said that God is
a dictator and he posed he imposes the
law and he has no mercy and look God
snuffed him out and so you know God is
exactly the way Lucifer said yeah so God
had to allow Lucifer who became Satan to
implement his plan of government yes so
that people would understand what a
disaster the universe would have been if
God allowed him to rule you know very
well said
um
one thing that I remember hearing you
say we discussed this quite some time
ago we tend to look at our suffering and
our woe and our pain and forget that God
is is suffering too he is suffering
through all of this one because his
Universe has been disrupted too because
a large portion of the people he created
and made rebuilt I say people
individuals entities that he created and
made rebelled against him and when he
came to to fix this situation on Earth
we crucified his son so God is suffering
also he has not been freed from
suffering and pain he's suffered through
the six seven thousand years of
suffering and would like it to end as
soon as possible but the train is late
in love and it's because he loves us
that he wants no one to be lost amen
amen so I think that's all we can say
about uh why God hasn't killed the devil
yet yet
because he will be destroyed oh yes
ultimately in the late the fire
according to Revelation 20. it's all
coming so Justice will be meted out
okay what is the second question here do
we know the background of sports and
should we as Christians get involved in
sports this question all went all the
way to the the floor of the General
Conference to the annual Council many
years ago about being involved in in
sports
um
the background of sports you know we
were talking about this just a little
bit
um
we go back to the The Grecian games and
of course even in other parts of the
world there there were there were games
and older things in in Rome uh I'll see
him yeah I guess you could call that
sport then there were some true sport
yeah but there were some things pitting
animals against humans also so mankind
has always wanted to test his ability
against other mankind men uh and so
um different activities were done where
men were physical against other men uh
and that of course is what the essence
of sport is the
can be healthy Sports we we dealt with
this
um in all the churches I pastored uh
being in an urban setting in New York
City we had a basketball team
um people like John lomakang played on
that basketball team uh Tim Nixon John
Nixon uh Tim Nixon's at Andrews
University now in the Pastoral staff
John Nixon is that southern pastors they
played on that same basketball team uh
that I played on uh we had a number of
doctors and lawyers and and people come
out
um
my thing was if you weren't in church on
Sabbath you weren't on the floor in the
game Saturday night you know you had to
I guess I sort of bribed them you had to
be in in church and Sabbath to play on
Saturday night
um so I think there can be some good the
thing is anything you you you spend all
your time in that you idolize takes the
wrong place and takes you away from the
Lord there is good Recreation we need to
step away you know Bob Ellen White says
it's not good to have your mind even on
religious things all the time you you
need to break you need to take a break
and to step back and and recreate uh and
sports can help you can help you do that
you know the bottom line is talking
about
um watching sports watching others do
sport so to speak uh you know has become
a type of idolatry yes some people will
dedicate hours and hours to watching
their favorite baseball team to watching
their favorite football team their
favorite hockey team and my question is
uh in comparison with how long you
dedicate to prayer and to Bible study
how much time do you dedicate to sports
it becomes a type of idolatry yes yes
you know
um and so you know practicing a sport
for example running or jogging is a
sport
um you know weight lifting is a sport
yes or even even having a friendly game
you know where you get together and you
have a baseball game together we used to
do that when I was a kid we used to go
to a park in the city of Caracas
Venezuela and the guys from the office
and several guys from the church we get
together we choose teams and we play
that was usually the last one to be
chosen because I was a lousy player but
but you know we we just had a good time
together I don't think that there's
particularly anything negative or bad
about that but when competition becomes
rabid to the point of I have to win it's
a different story by the way the Apostle
Paul used
um you know competition as a symbol of a
race in life in First Corinthians
chapter 9 and verse 24 he says do you
not know that those who run in a race
all run but but one receives a prize run
in such a way that you may obtain it and
everyone who competes for the prize is
temperate in all things he's he's
talking about Temperance yes you know
the the person who is going to do the
mile run or who's going to do a marathon
they have to train yes so he says and
everyone who competes for the prize is
temperate in all things now they do it
to obtain a perishable Crown but we for
an imperishable Crown yes therefore I
run thus not with uncertainty thus I
fight not as one who beats the air but I
discipline my body and bring it into
subjection lest when I have preached to
others I myself should become
disqualified and it's interesting in the
Christian race
everybody who was saved is a winner yes
very true whereas in sports there's
always one winner you know yes yes so
very very true he uses that metaphor and
it is a very apt metaphor and and very
very very plain well said um since there
are three parts of this questions should
Christian kids play video games
um
the majority of the video games that I
see
are not
wholesome
they are not
something that you want your mind to
dwell on you know the Bible says I will
set no Wicked thing before my eyes of
all of this shooting and Mayhem and
murder and raping and pillaging and some
of these games are really awful
um I don't think those are the kinds of
things now when we were growing up you
may remember this this this they had
things like Pac-Man uh the little the
little face
and and then you had that ping pong ball
that was bouncing you know games have
become much more sophisticated from when
we started uh but they haven't they
haven't gotten any better morally or or
in their ability to build up and not
tend down tear down they're mostly
pitting one group against another and
destructive and those are the kinds of
things Even in our selection of TV shows
the same criteria ought to be uh put
before does it build up does it tear
down does it brought me closer to God
does it take me away from God that
should be the the rubric we use for for
video games for television for music for
entertainment of any kind can God be
glorified by my participation in this
and sadly a lot of the video games that
is not so yeah the bottom line is that
we are changed into the image of that
which we behold and listen to very true
that is a principle of life it's kind of
like what we eat is what we are
physically what we eat through our eyes
and through our ears
makes us what we are spiritually yes
um and I remember when I was a teacher
in our University in Colombia that for
some strange reason which I don't
understand
the the
University rented a Bruce Lee movie
and it was on a Saturday night
and uh everybody was watching on yeah
yeah
and after the movie ended
everybody came out and everybody was
like yeah
now the question is where did they learn
that where did they learn to behave at
but when it went through their eyes
through their ears we are what we behold
if we behold Christ we become more like
Christ if we behold the world we become
more like the world it's a psychological
principle yes that cannot be changed and
that's why the Apostle Paul wrote but we
all with unveiled face beholding as in a
mirror the glory of the Lord are being
transformed into the same image yes from
glory to glory just as by the spirit of
the Lord and you know sometimes
I hear young people say uh I don't see
anything wrong with it
and I look at them and I said well I'm
going to pray that the Lord will fix
your eyes you know because if you don't
see anything wrong with that that's
serious yes and and then I'll say uh you
know could you invite Jesus to sit down
and play the video game with you where
there's killing as there's the occult
there's immorality could you invite
Jesus next to you to play that game
could you invite Jesus next to you to
watch some of the movies that are
presented in the movie theaters yes we
are what we see and what we hear it's a
law of Life yes and so we need to be
very careful about what we allow to
enter through the Avenues of our soul
yes by Behold Him we do become changed
and and you know our body is the temple
of God that that deals with not only the
food you put in but the the kinds of
media that you expose yourself to some
of this stuff is very very destructive
there's a reason why pastors have to
work so hard to keep people attentive
during sermons uh
because our competition is is the video
game our competition is the television
set our competition is the movie screen
um and so sometimes you gotta you gotta
try to say things in a way that that
titillates and that that adulterates the
gospel you want to give the truth the
plain truth but there are those who
don't want to hear the truth and the
plain truth because you've you feasted
six days on this stuff then you come to
church on Sabbath and the word of Truth
is boring because nobody's getting shot
nobody's getting killed nobody's in a in
a hot car chase because you fed Yourself
by that I remember we used to sing a
song when I was in school one night at
praying and six nights of fun
ought to go into heaven six to one you
know
so if you spend all your time or most of
your time or excessive amount of time
feeding yourself with these things then
the pure gospel is not going to be
interested because you're living on the
razor's Edge all the time and the gospel
is not that yep absolutely that's true
yeah so the bottom line is if you want
to have a spiritual relationship with
the Lord spend your time with the Lord
amen if you want to have uh you know a
spiritual relationship with the world or
an unspiritual relationship with the
world well then focus on the world
precisely what we watch and what we hear
makes us what we are physically and
spiritually and spiritually yeah amen
and amen well said all right now I think
we go
to
the question by Cube
valerikan yes let me just paraphrase
this question because it's not written
in the best uh syntax uh so let me just
synthesize
um he mentions or this person mentions
Exodus 16 23 the picking up of the manna
and he says well if the day begins when
the Sun goes down they certainly did not
go out to pick up pick up men in the
dark
and then he speaks about Jericho and he
makes some some
um some statements about the conquest of
Jericho that are not biblical for
example he says Joshua 6 3 and 4 clearly
states that for six days Sunday through
Friday
they would March around the walls of
Jericho one time but on the seventh day
Saturday would March around it seven
times when you re-read it it does not
say that the sixth day when the sun sets
they March around it at night
so what he's saying is uh that God said
go and pick up the manna uh in the go
pick up the Manna they didn't pick it up
at night they picked it up in the
morning and when the Bible says that
they marched around Jericho seven times
they didn't March at night they marched
in the morning so the day begins in the
morning it doesn't begin the evening
yeah that's the gist of his question uh
and then he he says Leviticus 23 does
say that you're supposed to keep the
Sabbath from evening to the evening but
that's talking about the Hebrew feasts
that's not talking about the days of the
week
um and uh then he gives some
contemporary thoughts he says
it does not start at night even the
Birds know that there are many
scriptures to support that God's Mercy
is new every morning when the day begins
the Bible doesn't say his mercies are
new at the end of the day at Sunset a
day never starts at night in the
creation if you notice he created all
day since the morning then the evening
came then the morning came and then he
created all day and then the evening
came then the morning came the sixth day
is preparation day and it's not the
Sabbath so how do we answer this
particular person who is asking this
question I believe the key is in Genesis
1 verse 5.
see in the Book of Genesis
there is a broad sense of a word
and there is a restricted sense of a
word within Genesis itself in fact in
Genesis 1 verse 5
there's a broad sense of the word day
and there's a restricted sense of the
word day it says there in Genesis
chapter 1 verse 5 God called the light
day
and darkness he called night
but then it says so the evening and
morning were the first day
so the word day describes the light
portion of the day
and it describes the entire day yes
so but the Bible is clear it says when
the evening and the morning of the first
day evening and morning of the second
day so why didn't God if the day starts
in the morning why not say morning and
evening of the first day morning evening
of the second day Etc yeah yeah the
bottom line is that
um the Bible uses the word day in a
broad sense of the entire 24 hours or
day in the sense of the lighted portion
of the day so when it says pick up Manna
in the morning
and that's the beginning of the day it's
talking about the day in a restricted
sense yes I don't know if you're
following me or not I am and when when
Jericho uh you know when they March
around Jericho uh for seven days and on
Seventh day seven times uh it's it's not
saying that they marched at night
because the day begins of the evening no
it's using the word day in the
restricted sense yes of the light
portion of the day and so that answers
every objection that this person is
making here in in this uh question or I
guess is not a question is a statement
yeah and and the fact that His Mornings
his his mercies are are new every
morning is because that's when you enter
into that day you pick a restricted part
of the restricted part of the day the
daylight part of the day right you that
and they are new when you are aware and
away they are there for you right and
tomorrow when you are aware and awake
they will be there for you they are new
every time you awaken enter into the day
so that's not the beginning of the day
day the day has already begun While You
Were Sleeping yeah and Jesus referred to
this uh in the Gospel of John chapter 11
he says I must work the works of my
father while it is day the night is
coming when no one can work well he's
saying I must work during the light
portion of the day so he's using it in a
restricted sense as well and of course
when he says the night is coming that
means when he can't work anymore so so I
think that the confusion here has to do
with the fact that the day has two
different definitions in Genesis
um
and and the word the heavens and earth
is also used in a restricted sense in a
broad sense in Genesis chapter 1 and
also male and female yes uh you know the
word man is used in a restricted sense
and in a broader sense the restricted
sense is mankind yeah you know and the
No No the perfect sense is male and
female right the broadest sense is man
which includes both yes so this is a
characteristic in Genesis well said well
said all righty thank you Cube
or Adam we have two names on this email
whichever one it is yeah we thank you
for for your question
all right
[Music]
um
Elisha or Alicia Ponte
um we don't know where it's coming the
Bible says after the fall of Man God
said man has become like one of us
knowing good and evil does it mean man
didn't originally have this knowledge of
good and evil before sin that's exactly
what it meant
um
that that man only knew good you know
Ellen White tells us that sin is an
interloper it is an insertion for which
there no reason can be given uh once man
sinned they knew the other side of the
coin but it was not God's plan or
intention for them to ever know that uh
was the Heaven and Earth were defined by
one way of doing things and that was
God's way sin is another way of doing
things and that was never God's
intention for us he wanted us always and
and and praise God my mind is jumping
back and forth that when When sin is
done we'll be back to one way of doing
things and that's God's way yeah and and
the word no there is much more than
knowing intellectually yes it's talking
about experience Adam and Eve had not
experienced evil God had experienced
evil because Lucifer sinned in heaven
yes so he knew what he knew what sin was
by experience not because he sinned but
because he he was there when Satan
sinned in his presence but Adam and Eve
God did not want them to experience to
know experientially because the word no
is not something that you know in your
head it's something that you experience
yes and so in that sense they did not I
don't mean did not know uh evil
Satan actually told Eve you know God has
only told you what's good but evil
that's great you just have to experience
it that is what the devil is really
saying yes yes yes that and of course he
has not changed his tactics uh all these
years you know I read something and and
our time is going to get away from us
that that that shook me years ago
Illinois says when Adam saw that first
leave fall from the tree he realized
that was a result of his activity now of
course uh people flocked to New England
to New York where I spent most of my
Ministry uh to see the leaves turn
colors and fall of the fall of the year
when they die but when Adam saw that
same thing it saddened him because it
was a a recognition that your sin caused
that to cause that to happen but even in
the fall we have a illustration of death
and Resurrection because when you go to
the east coast yeah and the trees have
no leaves they say man those trees are
dead right but then in the spring they
spread all these beautiful green leaves
you see the tree resurrected they did
and so you have the illustration of
death and Resurrection even after sin
amen and amen alrighty praise the Lord
well again we've come to the end of a
another half hour we've loved studying
the word of God and hopefully you've
been blessed by what we have studied
allow me again in closing to wish you
both Grace and peace through our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we'll see again
soon bye bye and God bless
foreign
[Music]